CHANDA: Just tell me
in very brief--
how do you define globalization?
FRIEDMAN: Well, I define globalization as the integration of markets, financial systems, telecommunications
systems,
and technologies
in a way that is shrinking the world
from a size medium to a size small
and enabling each of us, as individuals,
to reach around the world farther,
faster,
deeper, and cheaper
than ever before,
while at the same time enabling the world
to reach into each of us
farther,
faster,
deeper, cheaper than ever before.
CHANDA: Excellent. Very succinct definition, good.
Now move on to
the interview.
Since
Lexus and the Olive Tree
was published in 1999,
the world has changed.
And how do you see this change
has affected globalization
as a phenomenon?
FRIEDMAN: Well, you know, the most important
effect on globalization has clearly been 9/11.
It's really been
a huge a huge "olive tree" event--
CHADHA: If you could explain what the "olive tree" is--
FRIEDMAN: A huge assertion of--
ethnic or religious identity--
anger, rage--
into this globalization system.
But because it was targeted on the United States,
which after all is the heartbeat of the system,
it's slowed down the system a little bit. It's interdicted
travel a little bit. We see its impact on the airline industry.
I won't say it's interdicted trade but it's certainly
slowed down commerce.
It's put sand in the gears of the system.
Not in a fundamental way,
but the danger
that 9/11 poses:
if there's
another nine eleven
that prompts the United States
to really
shrink the apertures
into our country--
whether it's the Canadian border or our seaports or airports or rail lines--
that really could have an effect in slowing down globalization,
at least for a while. So
that's the biggest impact--
the biggest change since the book came out.
But the other important thing to keep in mind is that there are a lot of misunderstandings about
this.
A lot of people associated the dot-coms with globalization,
and so when the dot-coms blew up, people wrote that globalization is over.
Now, my answer to them is very simple: it's true that there no longer are five websites
where you can get 100 pounds of dog food delivered to your house in an hour.
But there's one.
And that's what's new. That's what you have to keep your eye on. People who say globalization's
over.
CHADHA: And that one is Amazon.com?
FRIEDMAN: Well, there's Amazon.com or one other that we don't know--
dogfood.com or pets.com if it still exists--
but--
I just used it as an example. But people
who say globalization is over--
I would like to introduce them to two
pretty good-sized countries: one's called India,
and one's called China.
These are two countries that have bet their future
on a globalization strategy.
On educating and empowering their people and designing their infrastructure, trade,
and governance policies to succeed in globalization.
They are two-fifths of the planet.
Go tell them
that globalization is over.
CHADHA: One of the features, you said-- the most striking feature of the globalization system, as opposed to the Cold War system,
is integration.
Do you see the integration aspect as being somewhat
hampered by what has happened since 9/11?
FRIEDMAN: There is no question
that one
just looks at a
place like Yale--
I don't know this, but I assume it--
that you have foreign students
that may have come for a semester, gone home, and not been able to come back from spring break
because of visa problems. A tiny example.
But I've had ambassadors around the world writing me about the problems they're having with
smart, bright kids
or professionals who have
job opportunities or
study opportunities in the United States
there haven't been able to take them up because of globalization.
CHADHA: That's a tough-- yeah--
FRIEDMAN: As a result, have not been able to take thump as a result of 9/11.
That will
slow down globalization if it's permanent. My guess is that there will be technological fixes to
all of these things.
Some of them may not be pretty, because some of them may involve infringements
on civil liberties as we've known them.
But there will be fixes over time. We're in the adjustment period now.
CHADHA: You know, in one of your
pieces you wrote
that Ramzi Yousef,
the guy who
blew up the World Trade Center the first time--
his desire to blow up the World Trade Center
was because,
as you said-- globalization as Americanization
had gotten in his face,
and it had empowered him
as an individual to do something about it.
Now, do you see Americanization and globalization as the same thing?
FRIEDMAN: I think that it was true to a point and it was certainly true early on, and it's
less and less true every day.
My image of globalization, when one speaks culturally--
I always ask people, "What's the most popular food in the world?
Is it the Big Mac?"
No, no. "Is it spaghetti?" No, no.
The most popular food in the world is pizza, ok?
Now why is pizza such a popular food?
Because every culture has a
flat piece of bread
on which you can stick all kinds of local
ingredients
and products. So in India you can get curry pizza,
and in China you can get sweet and sour pizza,
and in Mexico you can get chili pizza or fajita pizza.
And I look at kind of the Internet, which is so much of a driver of globalization,
as like a big pizza that every society
basically puts its own local culture on.
I don't know exactly when, but it'll be sometime near 2010,
where there'll be more Chinese and Indian Internet users
than there are Americans.
And that's going to change the flavor of the Internet pizza.
So yes,
initially America was the driver of this system,
and dominated in the cultural sense,
but I think it will be less and less true
with every passing day.
Chadha:
You also coined this phrase, "superempowered angry men,"
who are kind of challenging globalization in many ways.
But these people are products of globalization themselves,
but they are trying to create a different kind of globalized world-- is that right?
FRIEDMAN: Well, in some ways, yeah, they're products of globalization in that the hijackers of
9/11, some of them
booked their seats on Travelocity.com.
They were very adept at communicating through the Internet, even sending
encoded, embedded messages
with stenography as far as we can tell.
Cell phones were
a basic instrument of Osama Bin Laden for
passing messages and instructions.
They were global men in many, many ways.
And they have a global vision.
I call them Islamo-Leninists, ok?
Because in another life,
had Osama Bin Ladin or Ayman al-Zawahiri each had been students at Yale,
they would have been Trotskyites or Marxists.
These are people with utopian visions.
They want to bring the kingdom of God on earth.
But not the kingdom of a race,
like the Nazis.
Not a kingdom of class, like Marxists.
But a kingdom of a religion,
Islam.
CHADHA: And one of the things you said about
the need for
fundamentals
that countries need to have
in order to
better integrate to the globalized world, like
good governance, rule of law,
education,
and the stuff you said that cannot be downloaded.
Which is good.
The point is, the countries which are
unfortunate,
to be in a geographically
wrong area
or economically
not endowed,
how do you pull up these countries into the globalized world?
FRIEDMAN: Well, it's really
good governance in spades. Now, what do I mean by that?
the key the globalization
is not in the bandwidth.
It's not in the wires.
It's actually in the good old fundamentals.
You get your governance right and clean,
get your oversight and regulatory bodies that look over your banking system and financial
system
in decent shape,
give me a basic rule of law, that as a foreigner I can invest in your country
and feel that if there is a dispute between me and a local businessman, I can get it adjudicated
without having to bribe the judge with a goat, ok?
And you get those basics right and good education systems, so I have a pool of educated people to
draw from--
and you'll do fine.
You'll do fine if you're Taiwan. Think about Taiwan for a second. This is a barren
rock in a typhoon-laden see
off the coast of China.
With what, 20 million people on it?
It has the third-largest foreign reserves in the world.
It doesn't have climate going for it. It doesn't have natural resources going for it--
all it's got going for it:
good fundamentals.
So you get your fundamentals right?
The world will find you.
The wires will find you.
The bandwidth will find you.
Get 'em wrong,
and nobody will find you.
Or nobody will stick with you for very long.
So really,
success in globalization,
it's all about
that good old basic stuff, and that good old basic stuff
is open for any country to acquire.
How did Hong Kong succeed?
It succeeded with the basics.
Lord knows it has no natural resources.
CHADHA: Except the fact that some of the policies of the Western countries, developed countries,
especially the United States,
like steel tariffs,
the farm subsidy,
and also
the US attitude towards
the Kyoto Protocol, the International Criminal Court--
all this kind of suggests the US is trying to hew its own course.
At a time when the US is at the cutting edge of globalization
and the US is the major beneficiary of globalization. So how do you explain this contradiction?
FRIEDMAN: Nayan, you're far too polite.
It's not just a contradiction, it's a shameful
contradiction.
It's wanting to have it both ways.
It's wanting to force open other people's markets
for what we make and export
successfully
while keeping our markets closed
to some of the things they make and export successfully-- often food and textiles for developing
countries.
It's wrong.
It's a travesty. And it's the great Achilles' heel
of the globalization system. Someone told me the other day-- this might not be accurate--
but a friend of mine from India told me that
there was a study done about the farm subsidies for other countries,
and if you took all those subsidies and put them together,
you could fly every cow around the world first class.
Ok? So
I don't know if that's accurate, but I bet the direction is roughly right.
These are political questions.
Hopefully we'll eventually get over them.
I'm all for buying off steelworkers;
I'm all for buying off our farmers. Let's cushion them from the ravages.
But what I'm not for
is being stupid
and when someone is knocking on my door as a country and saying, "We'd like to sell you
steel for less than it costs us to make it,"
and we slam the door and say, "No no no, we don't want that"--
that's just stupid,
and that's what retards your growth as a country, so
we all need to take advantage of the system, but we need to make it fair,
and there I believe the third world,  the developing world has a big and
and justifiable complaint.
CHADHA: And that complaint, of course, is being expressed mostly
at the WTO forum.
FRIEDMAN: Yes.
CHADHA: And
do you have any thoughts as to
what should one do about
the intellectual property issue in WTO,
which is becoming a measure
of struggle in
global trade?
FRIEDMAN: I don't know enough about where the proper compromise should be there. But what I know is
this: people want to talk about whether we globalize, whether we should globalize--
them, I don't have much patience for. Because
globalization here is being driven by technology,
and this is the wave of the future.
But people want to talk about how we globalize--
how we do it technologically,
how we do it legally,
how we do it in terms of trade, and how we make it fair?
That's a discussion I'm ready to have all day long.
So I would have to defer to the experts on where the right compromise is
on issues like patents, but
it's certainly a discussion that we should be having.
CHADHA: And finally,
as you know, the [incoherent] theory of globalization in the late nineteenth
century
has abruptly ended.
The beginning of twentieth,
with the
tariff walls rising and immigration barrier rising--
do you see this,
the same phenomenon, reproducing again now with what's happening in Europe vis-a-vis
immigrants? Even in this country, about
immigrants from southern countries being
more difficult to receive?
How do you see this?
FRIEDMAN: Well, you know, the first era of globalization was really built around a fall in transportation
costs
thanks to the steamship and the railroad.
This era of globalization is built
on something different; it's built on falling telecommunications costs
and the transfer of voice and data and information
in an era of service economies.
I see it being hampered, potentially,
by the rise of
this terrorist phenomena and how it could
put sand in the gears of the system.
But unless you tell me that people are ready to accept radically lower standards of living,
I don't think
we will consciously,
as governments and societies,
want to go back
to the pre-globalization era.
Now, it may be that there's going to be a transition here where we find the technological ways. You know, I was just
at the Davos
World Economic Forum, and when you go there as a participant,
they give you a name-
tag which you wear around your neck, and it has your picture and barcode on it,
and you can go to a computer and get all your messages, and you can even--
when you go in and out of the Davos Conference Center,
you press this,
and it gets you entry, and your picture and your whole bio comes up.
We may be going to that system.
Certainly if there's another 9/11,
we're all going to be wearing Davos badges around our neck
to get into the airport, to get into the sports stadium,
to get into any public place.
That is, alas, I fear where we will go.
But where we won't go, I believe, is backwards to some prehistoric age.
CHADHA: In the last
several months, developments in Latin America, especially
Argentina,
Brazil, Peru,
are
leading people to say,
"Maybe Latin America is gonna sign off on globalization."
Do you see that
as a possibility?
FRIEDMAN: I don't see it at all. I see Latin America, I'm afraid, in my golden straitjacket,
struggling to find a way to succeed in this system
consistent with its own culture. The reason globalization is going on so successfully,
I think,
is more and more countries are learning how to globalize,
how to
fit their own culture, society, and social needs into the demands
of the global market. And the countries that are
doing the best, I think, are countries like India,
which hasn't opened up its markets fully--
or China,
which has gone slowly
into this
but at the same time moved ahead. I always say,
in this globalization system, there's just one road;
folks, there's just one road, but when someone comes and says they've found a whole new road
to prosperity,
oh, I grab my wallet. I know I came in here with fifty dollars, and I'm leaving with fifty dollars.
There's just one road, and it's the road of,
I believe, free markets,
or liberal markets, liberalized markets,
and liberalized politics.
But there are many speeds, Nayan.
There's one road, but there's many speeds, and every country
should go down the road
in a way that's consistent with
maintaining its cultural cohesion,
its social cohesion,
but at the same time its economic development. For some, it may be 500 miles an hour;
for others it may be 50.
But promise me you just won't do one thing:
not go down the road at all.
If you do that,
I promise you,
you'll bring nothing but ruin and devastation your people.
CHADHA: Excellent. Thank you very much. Thank you.
FRIEDMAN: My pleasure.